morris has booker on him
goes cross court to beverly
beverly crossover drives inside lamp is
good
patrick beverly with some razzle dazzle
on the offensive end he's got nine
points
he is talking smack on both sides of the
floor
crowder that won't go
and now i found down the other end as
the clippers look to go up the floor
crowder checks to make sure the groom's
okay
patrick beverly on the offensive end
[Applause]
dancing against chris paul lulls in the
sleep turns the corner he did a cp3 on
cp3
[Applause]
that's the most points he scored in this
series
got nine points on four of five from the
field
including a three-pointer and they're
going to look at that crowder foul
that was just called as the clippers
were coming up the floor
[Applause]
you love him when he's on his team
because of just how hard he plays how
emotional
he finals for the first time in 28 years
meanwhile the clippers hoping to force a
game seven and there's beverly picking
up his first
i think he agreed with it i haven't seen
that very often
[Music]
at first he wanted to in there now i
can't i can't
you